[Music]  in times of all the world was full of  wonder and magic but times change warner  mom hey birthday boy  by the laws of your I must dub thee a  man today kneel before me that's okay I  have a gift from your dad  he just said to give you this when you  were both over sixteen no way  it's a wizard step dad was a wizard what  your dad was an accountant  this spell brings him back for one all  day dad will be back  what Zach way back to life that's not  possible it is with this I'm gonna meet  dad  [Music]  ah hisses legs I definitely remember dad  having a top part uh what did I do  hi we only have 24 hours to bring the  rest of him back until then oh hey Dad  you look just like I remember  [Music]  we want a problem child  you see you come to the right time  Oh  we might be out of gas but it says we  have a full tank that doesn't work  growth spell we grow the can and then  the gas inside will grow with it  the can is huge and the fan is huge and  your  [Music]  you